[Musique]
par les agniers première vague lors de
la première rencontre a essayé de rester
discret vous faites pas repéré elle est
dite tapie dont elle vous repèrent pas
bien assez tôt à l'homme idéal pour
avoir un enfant
je sais pas ouais vincent cassel vincent
cassel prêt d'arriver en main mais on
pensait jamais un voilà c'est vrai je
vous jure jean michel aulas a cru que
j'allais dire monica bellucci et comme
s'était lancé l'ancienne compagne de la
potel machinalement que du coup eh ouais
à défaut de mer on manque de grip on
sait numéro 2 les enfants une fois vous
avez établi le contact avec mode target
ce soit par leur gao par la parole
faites comme si vous étiez insensible à
son regard on va bien assez tôt dans vos
filets et demi beaucoup passent à vienne
on est un petit truc en partie scrutant
les regards
vous pensez que vous non je la regardais
en tout cas madame vous pensez qu'en
sardaigne vous pour être son style a
déclaré courage de l'avouer je pense
fabienne on va attendre la fin d'année
commenté dire quoi mais non mais a dit
le tube elle me l'aurait dit et ça c'est
très gênant là conseil numéro trois si
la situation semble bloquée si vous
n'arrivez pas à obtenir un rendez-vous
près de la belle faites confiance à
votre bonne étoile
votre destin les choses finissent
toujours par arriver et croyez moi ma
belle tu es une coccinelle juste la
regarde oui c'est pas très grave
a nantes la taxe c'est fait alors du
rallye demain soir jean-michel non merci
[Musique]
c'est du nord 4 jetés par les jours pas
favorable alors pour parfois savoir
forcer sa destinée la seule solution
être là au bon moment à la bonne place
n'apparaît pas tous en même temps les
chéris vous connaissez qu'il vous a déjà
relégué
non non à tin est ensemble et en fait on
s'est rencontrés parce qu'il y avait
toutes les types d'eurosport la même
table il est venu à côté d'où il est
resté et au loin de ses copains mais non
ils étaient rangés pourtant une petite
étiquette à côté de l'origine même et
alors conseil numéro 5 les amis ça y est
vous avez enfin obtenu un premier rendez
vous la règle d'or laissez-la parler ne
vous vantez pas ne parlait pas de vous
et celles à dire ce qu'elle a envie de
vous dire voilà ça c'est très important
des amis n'oubliez jamais ça ça c'est
primordial des gars là ne crois pas ce
que vont dire les autres j'ai pas du
tout de maladie même si j'ai 50 ans
voilà je suis la bonne ma prostate est
en très bon état gélifiant pause entre
les orteils métier pas mais je suis pas
drôle mais moi c'est pas moi je vais
t'offrir des enfants je t'offre est une
vie une vie ou ce qui ne sera pas du
film et qui nous dit qu'il sera fait
d'horaires là ce qu'il dit me voilà
c'est fait faire à manger bigorneaux
blasco l'inconnu mais hier on a connu
pour être moins mais moins gentil il
était à chier
[Musique]
conseil numéro 6 le dîner s'est bien
passé maintenant faut lâcher les chevaux
des fois de soi même pour être sincère
sur tout accord donc on parler de soi
mais dire la vérité
toujours très important ça et comme ça
c'est sûr elle vous choisi ralentir le
physique est très important pouvoir et
franchement tu es sublime talissieu
visage voilà qui exploite expressif et
puis retombe très sensuelle mais c'est
vrai que j'y attache beaucoup
d'importance qui règne pour ça déjà
j'aurais youri de bras des merengues en
discutant un peu avec toi
csaba son qu'il ya au-delà de l'image
par une sensibilité à l'ofce aussi mais
personne ne le découvre chez moi parce
que je pense que je souffre aussi de ta
beauté mais j'y prends pas un moment ça
s'enchaîne bien sûr michel je respecte
son choix
quand il me dit je te promets je
regarderai une autre je regarderai plus
aucune autre part et jesse parce que
c'est un choix définitif
[Musique]
le grand moment est arrivé le moment du
baiser
s'il faut faire mokhtar le cbc faire 90
% à 80 % tiré 80 % du chemin la fille
n'avait plus que les 20 derniers % ou la
laisser absalon c est après ou le cobra
et mc cartney 80 % gratuit se facturent
pas cela
[Musique]
bien des conseils d amis qu'on sait
numéro 8
voilà au final on va la garder un
certain niveau d'exigence
d'accord on n'est pas des chiens de la
casse la fantasque respecte et nous
suspectons n'essayez pas de pêcher
n'importe quoi voilà on reste à tête
haute
loeb qu'une chasse à l'écart
non
[Musique]
il en a
nokia compte tant
[Musique]
n
ça alors là ça y est tu as fait chaud
parfait mais j'ai presque y avait les
boules